okay so let's take a break from
spider-man for a minute since we've been
covering a lot of that recently and
let's talk about donnie kate's hulk
which by the way this is drawn by ryan
otley not gonna lie it's a little weird
to see donnie kate's writing a comic and
ryan stegman not drawing it those are
the ones who did venom for those of you
guys who don't know uh it was really
really good so those guys are kind of
like a one-two punch to a degree but uh
but this is the beginning of the new
incredible hulk story arc under donny
case so we are finished with al ewing's
immortal hulk that's kind of a
self-contained story all right this one
kind of builds off of it but we may do a
full story let me know if you guys are
interested in seeing like an immortal
hulk full story video i don't think
we've done that yet but something else
to also keep in mind is that this is a
monthly series so this will be coming
out once every month uh so we won't be
covering it like every week or every day
like we'll cover them as they come out
but what this does here is this
basically picks up with the incredible
hulk like punching against a wall which
is kind of a weird thing right it's
literally just like a giant door kind of
out in the middle of nowhere and we get
this sort of you know exposition here
right it says things like you know i
have long held a theory about the hulk
uh that i've never shared it before
because quite frankly it terrifies me to
the very core that we've always thought
of the hulk as the manifestation of dr
banner's trauma that he experienced as a
child or perhaps his id his shadow his
fury and then the question becomes but
what if the hulk is none of those things
what if it exists to protect us from
banner himself and that's a cool thing
right so one of the great things about
donnie kate's those guys who don't know
he's very very very very good at looking
at the status quo for an existing
character and then flipping it on its
head and so what you end up doing is
actually switching to this discussion
between bruce banner and betty ross and
it's kind of a crazy thing because of
course he tells you know betty you're
not supposed to be here and she really
approaches him with this conversation
about what he's doing with the hulk that
he can't simply keep the incredible hulk
locked into that particular location now
this is kind of interesting because what
donnie kate's is doing is kind of toying
with us a little bit in relation to like
jason aaron's incredible hulk run and
then like the traditional incredible
hulk mythos and the reason why i say
that is because as you guys know with
the traditional incredible hulk mythos
the hulk is a manifestation of banner so
they're basically two different people
sharing the same body right like bruce
banner physically transforms into the
incredible hulk what jason aaron did
during his run on hulk is he actually
wrote a story whereby the two of them
were split so you had bruce banner in a
separate body from the incredible hulk
and that's happened over the years right
during the onslaught saga for example
the psychic consciousness of bruce
spanner was removed from the incredible
hulk in order to provide a kind of just
pure savage hulk that was really the
most powerful version of his character
we'd seen up to that point that was the
only real means to basically defeat or
at least find a way to defeat onslaught
that kind of a thing and so donnie kate
isn't really creating new ground here
he's kind of retreading existing ground
but doing it in his own way which is a
cool thing and so ultimately banner's
response to betty is one of hostility at
least as it pertains to the hulk that
betty kind of views the incredible hulk
is very much like a child and he really
is right the incredible hulk is very
childlike in terms of how he operates
unless you're talking about world
breaker hulk or something like that but
savage hulk is very very childlike in
that way and so what betty says is that
she's concerned about this because
hurting the incredible hulk is hurting
banner and it's one of those things
where she's like you can't blame
yourself for what happened in el paso
now for those of you guys who are
approaching this from the perspective of
okay did i miss something from immortal
hulk no you didn't there was a recent
interview that donnie cates did where he
answered that question because it was
the one thing that people wanted to know
was like okay did we miss something from
immortal hulk that happened in el paso
or something like that and during his
interview with comicbook.com he said no
like it's a thing that has not been
revealed yet it's just something that
took place between the end of immortal
hulk and the beginning of this run but
whatever it was that took place out
there banner just kind of freaks out and
says he doesn't really blame himself he
blames the incredible hulk and so
ultimately his feelings about how the
world perceives him really come out and
manifest here and this is something that
you don't readily see from banner where
betty says that like you're scaring me
right you can't act like this you don't
sound like yourself then the responsive
manner is and how would you know what i
sound like right how would anybody know
the only time i'm ever useful to any of
you all is when i'm not here when you
need the incredible hulk and he says i
never wanted any of this right i never
wanted to be a superhero or a defender
or an avenger or a monster he's like i
never wanted to do any of this stuff all
i wanted to do was push boundaries all i
wanted to be was a man of science and so
he says at the end of the day it didn't
work like none of that happened and so
because of that he says like this this
whole thing right like this incredible
hulk it grew inside of me like some kind
of a tumor some kind of an illness you
know and and i was a fool to believe
that it would ever stop growing in the
first place to believe that i could
somehow control the hulk or contain the
hulk that after the events of of dealing
with the one below all and the one above
all that i somehow had a stronger grasp
on all this i was a fool to believe any
of that but more so than that the
biggest concern that bruce banner has is
that at some point in time the
incredible hulk is going to manifest
he's going to take over and his fear is
not that the incredible hulk is going to
kill his friends or anything like that
is that the incredible hulk we'll stay
that way that banner will never come
back out again right the incredible hulk
will basically find a way to stay in
control and you'll never ever see banner
he'll lose himself and that's one of the
funny things where again donnie kate's
is building on history here specifically
with peter david's the incredible hulk
the end for those of you guys who never
read that story it was a phenomenal
story where basically the incredible
hulk was the last living thing on earth
right we're not really a thing he was a
last living uh superhero last living
person on earth and that all that was
left after this just catastrophic
nuclear war was basically just him and
like giant bugs that would eat him on a
daily basis and he would heal himself
and all that kind of stuff but there's
one point near the end of the story or
really at the end of the story where he
lashes out his banner who's basically
grown old and he screams at banner that
like i want you to go away right hulse
just wants to be alone and then the
banner persona basically dies of old age
however that works and so because of
that the incredible hulk is eternally
left alone on earth like he'll just be
on earth forever and that'll be it until
such a time that either earth is
colonized by some alien race or life
begins anew and begins to evolve that
the incredible hulk will seemingly just
live on forever as the only occupant of
the planet earth itself unless he finds
a way to leave the important thing is
this is one of those stories that donnie
kate is referencing here and so it's
kind of an interesting thing because in
the end we kind of find out to agree
what's really going on here when banner
tells betty ross get out of my head
right like get out of my head and leave
me alone this is how it might as well
end and so what he does here is he sits
on what's basically like a captain's
chair and then he says like these waves
do not crash on me they break on me
because i i am strong and then from
there you basically switch over to the
avengers i know it's weird but it makes
perfect sense here in a second and i
really love what donnie cates is doing
here right so the first thing you do is
you pick up with spider-man who's
basically talking to the rest of the
fully assembled avengers and the
fantastic four and the question that's
asked is like okay is anybody else super
confused about what's going on here
and the response of doctor strange is
what bruce banner has managed to achieve
here goes beyond anything anybody has
done right that in effect the incredible
hulk becomes the single most powerful
being on the face of the planet and
here's the reason why it's one of those
things where you can kind of extrapolate
it but the idea is that when doctor
strange starts talking about this he
says that what he's built that not even
dr strange could have achieved it right
the doctor strain says he scoured the
earth searching and questioning every
mystic and omega level telepath that he
could possibly find to see if they could
do such a thing and none of them could
bruce banner managed to achieve
something that the most powerful beings
on the face of the planet were unable to
do himself but then strange says there's
no way that banner could have done it
himself that it just doesn't make any
sense the magic required is just beyond
anything and so at the end of the day of
course captain america kind of reels
them back in and says tell us what's
going on and so what we end up learning
here is that bruce banner had basically
fractured his mind into three distinct
parts and by unifying these parts but
controlling them individually he's
basically made what's being referred to
as a starship right now the term
starship is a loose term here this is
not something like the end of like
moonwalker right where like michael
jackson turned into a ship and flew away
that's not what we're talking about here
it's it's the phrase or the term
starship in relation to basically how
the incredible hulk exists right now now
the other thing about this is that the
incredible hulk is making its way
towards one degree mountain looking for
a particular thing and it's kind of
crazy because along the way he's
basically fighting iron man and four
hulkbuster armors which is nuts and he's
overpowering them all but what doctor
strange tells us is that these three
distinct parts are eloquently designed
and really work as a singular cohesive
unit what banner had done first and
foremost is he had stolen technology
from advanced idea mechanics and then
basically used that technology to
enhance the skin for lack of a better
word of the incredible hulk basically
he's made the incredible hulk more
durable than he was before as if he
needed it the incredible hulk was
already one of the most durable beings
out there like being able to
successfully physically injure the hulk
is no small thing i mean you could make
his nose bleed if you were strong enough
right like the thing has done that but
if you're talking about like literally
cutting the hulk removing a limb or
something like that you need something
like adamantium possibly vibranium and
most likely something like carbonadium
or the muramasa blade in order to pull
that off you would need a highly
specialized weapon to achieve that what
banner's done here is basically push
that durability beyond what we've
previously seen with this character and
we'll actually see how far deep that
goes because it gets nuts the second
thing that banner's done is he's built
this giant mind palace like nothing dr
strange has ever seen before so much so
that there's not a singular telepath on
earth that can get through it no one can
break through it emma frost professor
xavier of the x-men no one can break
through this psychic barrier that bruce
banner has erected in the mind of the
incredible hulk and then following that
of course you have this kind of you know
conversation not really a conversation
so much just taunting back and forth
between banner and iron man right where
it's kind of like you know yeah yeah you
can't beat me so on and so forth but
like he crushes them all in terms of the
durability of iron man this is where
things get cool so one of the things
that he does here is he basically fires
off what are basically these rockets
that have adamantium nanoparticle
shrapnel inside of them in effect what
happens these are like little just tiny
shards of adamantium they barrel
themselves into the body of whatever
their target happens to be and then due
to their nano programming they basically
forge the adamantium at an atomic level
in effect adamantium grows from the
inside out and so for the incredible
hulk this is designed to grow in the
form of a cage to basically lock him
down in place and so that's when you get
into the third thing or the third aspect
of what bruce banner's done here that
the incredible hulk itself is powered by
range right as you guys know the angrier
the incredible hulk gets the stronger he
gets what if you were able to find a way
to weaponize that and so that's what
banner's done that banner sitting in
this kind of captain's chair is
basically controlling the body of the
incredible hulk but what of the
incredible hulk's consciousness banner
has actually taken that and locked it
away and that's what you saw in that
opening scene when he was punching on
that door that banner has imprisoned the
psyche of the incredible hulk and then
basically subjects him to constant
bombardment by enemy forces whenever he
needs him to become angry and because
the incredible hulk is childlike the
incredible hulk is going to attack
whatever it is that's attacking him and
he's going to become angrier the longer
the conflict goes on because these are
basically infinite armies that would be
attacking him he would just become
angrier and angrier and angrier
basically bruce banner's found a way to
weaponize the incredible hulk's rage
that rage is the engine that bruce
banner is using so what's basically
going on here to kind of give you guys a
better perception is that bruce banner
used technology to modify the body of
the incredible hulk to make him more
durable he in turn took over the mind of
the incredible hulk and he uses the
incredible hulk's rage to decide how
angry or how powerful the incredible
hulk is going to get so basically just
imagine that at any point in time in any
fight that uh that bruce banner could
just amp the incredible hulk up to like
world breaker levels on a win that's
what we're talking about here weaponized
world breaker hulk it's nuts and so in
this conflict because of the fact that
the adamantium is basically holding him
in place and not even the incredible
hulk is strong enough to physically
break through adamantium he actually
rips his arm out of it and when he does
it literally tears his arm off like
which is kind of crazy so he's basically
pummeling tony stark with one arm
against all these hulk buster suits
right like literally all these
hulkbuster suits that he has are getting
totally obliterated with his one arm and
then he takes one of the arms of the
hulkbuster suits and attaches it to his
snapped arm right to his arm that was
ripped off and then just goes forward
from there and so what you end up
finding is that the immortal hulk
traveling here of course once his arm is
basically healed which really only took
a couple of minutes right if that maybe
like 30 seconds to fully heal which
gives you a real indication of just how
powerful and durable he is that what he
was looking for was actually something
that tony stark built project arc so the
idea behind this is that in the
aftermath of the events of king and
black when null had attacked the world
that null overcame the world super fast
right showing up with celestials
different things like that and tony
stark who is ever the futurist began
developing a kind of suit of armor that
would serve one part as protection and
then one part as basically a gateway as
a wormhole and that's why you see in its
chest is what looks like a giant portal
energy source where the arc reactor
would normally be and what would happen
here is that in a time of a massive
emergency he could actually evacuate the
world's population through this thing
now the other thing about it and those
of you guys who are x-men fans is
probably not lost on you this looks like
master mold and i have to believe
there's probably a reason for that but
what this looks like because of the fact
that tony stark piloted a celestial is
that it looks like it's a celestial
killer armor is what it looks like right
like iron man's celestial killer armor
which is kind of nuts but at the end of
the day the response of hulk is i'm
gonna need to borrow this so you know
despite tony stark begging for him not
to that the math is not complete he has
no idea where he'll go if he passes
through that portal if you'll basically
take control of the suit of armor itself
or if you'll end up in some hellish
dimension or the realm of mephisto or
the negative zone there's no way to know
what'll happen the responsive banner is
i don't care it doesn't matter to me
what i want to achieve is more important
so he literally travels through the
portal to a future destination and we
have no idea what awaits him there
all right what's going on guys this is
rob and i forgot
that hulk number two was coming out two
weeks after hulk number one now after
this it's only coming out every month so
we'll have to wait like a month before
we cover the next issue i know it sucks
one of the things a lot of you guys have
voice to concern about is that sometimes
it's hard to keep track of stories so
what i'm gonna do is i'm actually just
gonna kind of create playlists for the
individual stories that we're doing so
they're super easy to follow we'll
probably end up with a million playlists
but there's no such thing as too many
playlists on youtube so for those of you
guys who are following devil's reign
you'll actually find a link to the
playlist in that video which right now
only has one video and then for this one
uh you'll find a link to the playlist uh
both for this individual story arc and
this video will also be added into the
main playlist for the incredible hulk so
that'll make it easier to follow along
having said that so in the first video
what we kind of talked about and what we
ran over here was really the change that
was going on with the incredible hulk
this idea that what banner had done in
the aftermath of like everything that al
ewing had done which was just a
ridiculously amazing story which we
still need to release a full story for
for immortal hulk um that what's
happened here is banner has basically
weaponized the incredible hulk in so far
that he basically turned him into a ship
because the incredible hulk is so
incredibly durable and so powerful he
can survive in almost any environment
and one of the things that was
established in jason aaron's run is that
the incredible hulk's physiology can
actually adapt to an environment so he
wasn't able to breathe underwater until
he was
and so what this means is that with
banner basically controlling the mind of
the incredible hulk and the incredible
hulk's rage being used as quote unquote
the engine that drives the ship that
he's basically able to do almost
anything he wants to and so far is
executing plants we don't really know
what this plan is what we do know is
that banner basically seized control of
basically celestial tech and then in
turn traveled into the multiverse now
the funny thing about this is that as
soon as he leaves his universe he comes
across a group that's referred to as the
alternate universe timeline hazard
operations response and intervention
team with some other word that starts
with a y it's authority this looks like
authority from dc comics those guys who
don't know that is the authority is
actually a group that operates
essentially in the multiverse but they
they well they've served different
purposes but they're a wild storm team
uh we haven't really talked about them
and maybe we should we haven't really
done much in the way of of wild storm
but this is hilarious because at the end
of the day he just plows through
[Laughter]
i mean none of these guys really have a
chance but it is kind of a funny thing
to see i mean tell me this ship in the
background does not look like the ship
of the authority from wildstorm they're
basically a pastiche right maybe they're
not exactly those characters they're
basically a pastiche but when it comes
to the multiverse this is one of the
things i want to talk about we i like to
reiterate this every so often for people
who are either new or who have been here
for a while and need a bit of a
refresher there are a lot of teams that
patrol the multiverse for different
reasons like the exiles travel from one
universe to the other just basically
solving problems and we should cover the
original like not really the original
but like the exiles run uh that
basically went into what was basically
house of m and all that kind of stuff
did like the world tour storyline and
all that we should probably cover that
because the exiles are like the most
underappreciated but more most amazing
team in marvel comics like literally
it's just a team that travels to
alternate realities all their like every
one of their stories was awesome there
was never a boring story in the exiles
but nonetheless these guys are
obliterated pretty quickly
the other thing behind this is that
banner is basically asleep at the wheel
and it kind of makes sense right i mean
it's a pretty exhausting situation to be
in controlling a giant green rage
monster and then you know sitting him
into space a lot's happened over the
course of the day a lot's happened over
the course of the day so once banner
starts to wake up what you actually end
up finding out here is they're being
targeted and the reason why is because
there's somebody out there or something
out there that's trying to get their
hands on the hulk for reasons we don't
necessarily know we simply know that
they are but again this is the nature of
using the incredible hulk's rage as an
engine system that where this really we
could call it kind of a physical tractor
beam is trying to pull the the
incredible hulk in that banner amps his
rage up right as a means to just kind of
keep the or at least push the incredible
hulk to higher levels think of this as
something akin to like nos in a car
except you can regulate how much nos you
basically allow in that car and you
basically have it just increasing in
power forever right is is kind of the
big difference here but again like
monsters are basically introduced that's
set upon the incredible hulk one of
which is fenfang fume uh spoilers have
you guys played the guardians of the
galaxy game yet dude that game is
amazing i just finished it like a couple
days ago dude that game is amazing
finfang foom looked awesome in that game
when they when they're like we need to
go find fen fang fum i was like yes
i really can't wait to see this but the
thing behind this is that again these
are just monsters and the incredible
hulk in what's essentially his his
almost like infantile form his savage
form just sees them as a credible threat
and attacks them that's one of the
benefits that banner's kind of waiting
for when it comes to the incredible hulk
if the incredible hulk is not figured
out this is an illusion now this is one
of the big differences between what
donnie cates is doing and what al ewing
is doing that in a lot of ways al ewing
depicted the intelligence of the
immortal hulk or at least his ability to
understand his surroundings as being on
par with banner right i mean the
immortal hulk was not as intelligent as
banner right it wasn't one of those
things where he's like practicing
science and things like that certainly
not on the same level the banner was but
he was certainly a lot more cognizant of
what was going on around him right he
was able to understand what was taking
place in a more nuanced way than what
savage hulk is able to do now whether or
not this means the immortal hulk slash
devil hulk persona is gone forever or is
temporarily just kind of retreated it's
something that only time will tell right
we'll just kind of have to wait and and
watch as donnie kate's run progress to
find out how this happens but regardless
what the immortal hulk's anger being
amped up more and more at the end of the
day banners told that the origin of this
entity is unknown but according to their
sensors they're being scanned and when
it turns out they're being scanned for
gamma radiation the initial response of
banner is it's the avengers right like
they're trying to find him or they have
found him and they're basically trying
to bring this guy back right they're
trying to reel him back into the
universe because the reality is he's not
supposed to be out there right like he
he overpowered the avengers in order to
get to this and so following that you
basically have him of course taking out
finn fang foom and you know the the
incredible hulk destroys these forces or
whatever and so banner needs more rage
and so as a really great throwback he
basically amps him up and has a giant
version of wolverine appear here now on
the surface you would think that if what
banner wanted to do was to maximize the
rage of the hulk that he would somehow
find a way to unlock the world breaker
hulk rage level right to make him you
know as angry as he's as he's ever been
but there's a couple reasons for why we
can surmise this is not really happening
the first is that to go from just hulk
who's kind of chill and relaxed or at
least is you know kind of minimally
angry we can call him that until like
world breaker hulk could possibly just
destroy his form right like i mean
destroy the the engine so to speak right
the other part of this is that given the
fact that the the world breaker hulk
form is essentially a more cognizant and
intelligent version of savage hulk that
what this would mean is that it would
figure out us all an illusion right like
world breaker hulk would figure out
what's going on and then basically just
stop right and just just cease to fight
and just kind of maybe revert back to a
base form and call it a day there's a
few different reasons for why we can
discern that's not necessarily happening
the other cool thing here is that this
being a throwback is to the old
wolverine first appearance when he
fought the incredible hulk this is how
he looked right this is this is how
wolverine looked back in the day not
only that as most of you guys know uh
the incredible hulk and wolverine have
had some ridiculously good fights
especially with that animated movie
right hulk versus and it's like
wolverine and thor you guys remember
that movie that movie was awesome i'm
gonna watch that movie as soon as i
finish with this video but it was a it
was a great movie right it was it was a
great thing i absolutely loved it uh but
there's been some great battles here
right and there's a lot of i wouldn't
say animosity but wolverine kind of
represents this being that's very
difficult for the incredible hulk to
take out and so the incredible hulk's
rage just kind of keeps going and going
and going but as the fight breaks on or
continues on between wolverine and uh
and and the incredible hulk the hulk's
not getting as angry as he needs to be
the engines themselves are also critical
so it's almost as though the engines
kind of match what the hulk is going
through now you do get some cool moments
right where like giant wolverine goes
you know goes to stab the immortal hulk
and his claws get stuck in the ground
and hulk rips out one of wolverine's
claws which is awesome it's just
ridiculously cool to see but the the
this kind of disembodied betty ross
right who almost seems to be a voice in
banner's head to a degree seemingly his
conscience kind of chimes in and is like
you're pushing the incredible hulk too
far like if you keep on doing this
either he's gonna break he's gonna shut
down and he's basically like that that
persona is gonna be destroyed possibly
replaced with another or simply just
losing your ability to power this engine
entirely or everything is going to go
belly up the crazy thing about this is
that if this version of the incredible
hulk is seemingly defeated slash
destroyed that what would happen is
banner would revert back into his human
form right like remember all this is
essentially taking place in the
mindscape right like this ship that
banner's sitting in is the brain of the
incredible hulk and the incredible hulk
himself is just his persona fighting all
these enemies that banners making him
see that appear to be real but actually
aren't right that's one thing to keep in
mind this is not happening on some
planet somewhere right that's that's not
really what's going on here but that if
this version of the incredible hulk is
defeated or destroyed that the
incredible hulk will revert back in into
his human form and banner cannot
withstand the rigors of the multiverse
in his current form right like as a
human being he cannot withstand that he
would basically be destroyed and so
that's why there's a bit of desperation
here that's why there's a bit of a
desire to to kind of push the incredible
hulk more and more and find some way to
get past this ultimately though the
incredible hulk succumbs to this this
kind of tractor system that's pulling
him in and there's no conceivable way
for them to find a way out and so
essentially once they're pulled back in
here or into this particular location
they crash land in what basically looks
like a cave with a kind of stasis field
that's keeping the incredible hulk in
place now we're not really given the
details of this stasis field and in
reality we don't really need them but i
would surmise that given how it's
technology-based it's likely one of
those things where it basically
reinforces the strength of the
incredible hulk so for every punch he
doles out that level of strength is
amplified two times over by the shield
so basically the shield is always more
durable than the incredible hulk is
right like the incredible hulk strength
works against him and being able to try
to break out of this thing the crazy
thing is that there's just this kind of
guy out there right like this this
person out there that you can't really
make out that says that like after all
these years they finally caught it right
they finally caught this person and
where banner doesn't know what's going
on right like who in the hell are you
like what what in the heck is happening
here the the person kind of chimes in
and says wow you're wildly different
from all the rest of them right you can
speak you can reason and you're in
control like this is kind of weird like
don't be afraid i mean you no harm my
name is dr bruce banner this looks like
bruce banner from an alternate reality
now try as i might this is not an
existing version of bruce banner that
i'm familiar with and i've searched high
and low this is not a version of banner
that we've seen before so it's not like
the incredible hoax landed in like the
house of m universe and this is banner
in that universe this is a seemingly a
reality that we've never seen before
which makes me
wildly excited to see what donnie case
is going to do here
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with the hulk right with uh
with hulk part three and and i don't
know why i keep getting the wires
crossed with like donnie cates and al
ewing like in the venom video we were
like it's donnie case's venom but it's
actually al ewing's venom it's probably
because the two of them directly
switched stories which always throws me
off donnie case was writing venom
alleywing was writing hulk then they
switched and donnie case is writing hulk
and alewing's writing venom and it just
it takes me for a loop sometimes so i
may make that mistake a couple more
times hopefully not i'll try to make
sure i don't but the whole idea behind
the incredible hulk because donnie cates
is writing it right now is that
basically bruce banner is piloting the
incredible hulk
now if you want to get caught up make
sure you guys check out the playlist
down in the description which will not
only have this incredible hulk story all
the way at the bottom but we'll also
have a whole bunch of other incredible
hulk stuff to go along with it including
the immortal hulk but the whole thing
behind this is that banner is basically
in an alternate reality and the crazy
thing is that this alternate reality
he's in is one that's actually occupied
by a another version of bruce banner now
before we get into that there is
something really important here and this
is one of those instances where dottie
cates teases a thing and then kind of
gives us this slow introduction it's
usually what he always does you could
set your watch to it right so he'll give
us like the first two issues which will
set the stage and then we'll get issue
number three which is something's coming
and then we'll get issue number four
which may or may not focus on that and
then with five and six we'll basically
come to the fruition of what's going on
with the thing he discussed assuming
he's gonna keep it confined to those six
issues and not really like build it up
as something that'll show up in like you
know 12 or 24 issues later on down the
line but the thing about this and really
the big question that we'd all had is
that at the end of al ewing's run on the
immortal hulk that banner and hulk had
basically kind of found a way to work in
unison right there was harmony there as
there usually always is when it comes to
the ending of a hulk story what we
didn't know is what had happened between
the time of the ending of immortal hulk
and the events in el paso when things
had basically popped off and the
incredible hulk had somehow lost his
mind and started tearing everything up
that what had basically happened is
things had kind of gone back to the
status quo but basically whenever the
incredible hulk essentially came on that
where he and banner would kind of work
in unison and both would basically know
what the other one was doing that banner
was basically shut out and so things
started going nuts and he didn't fully
understand what was happening the other
part of this is that when the when the
questions asked what happened like like
you know his belief being that like the
incredible hulk had basically just taken
over shut banner's mind out and then
went on a war path in el paso killed a
whole bunch of people and then basically
you know kind of reverted back into
banner that instead there's something
else going on here that seemingly
there's another kind of hulk presence
that's there almost demonic in nature
and then just basically refers to banner
as being weak and then kills banner
right off the bat now of course this is
him seemingly having like a dream
experience it's not actually him
experiencing that so we don't know
exactly how this unfolded if it was a
vision that took place in el paso if
it's something that he's just imagining
right some sort of way for him to kind
of cope with the the things that like
the incredible hulk actually did in el
paso we don't necessarily know all we
know is that he basically wakes up in
this alternate reality and is met with
this version of bruce banner now the
crazy thing about this is that this
alternate reality version of banner as
he says he describes him as being
magnificent and says i have never met an
abomination with such agency before and
so seemingly in this alternate reality
there appears to be more than one hulk
and those various versions that are out
there don't really have the same kind of
intelligence that bruce banner does now
the funny thing about this is that this
is kind of the exception to the rule
whether it's because of the fact that
bruce banner is basically controlling
the incredible hulk so like piloting the
hulk and using the hulk's anger as a
means to essentially control his body to
increase his strength or decrease his
strength as needed or previous
iterations where you had like professor
hulk or even like world breaker hulk or
something like that that regardless of
the situation seemingly this alternate
reality version of banner has never
encountered that and so when the the
main marvel universe banner introduced
himself as i am basically bruce banner
and i'm controlling the incredible hulk
i'm piloting him basically like my mind
is controlling the body then this
alternate reality version of banner is
like okay that's interesting i'm curious
about this and so of course with the
incredible hulk persona it really is his
mind kind of facing off against all
these different threats that banner
shuts the threats down which of course
lead to the incredible hulk persona
basically calming down right remember
that's how this whole thing works the
incredible hulk is basically the engine
that you have the physical incredible
hulk's body but you have the mind of
bruce banner that's controlling the
incredible hulk's body and that what you
have is the incredible hulk mind
basically the savage hulk's mind being
forced to fight enemy after enemy after
enemy increasing his rage which allows
the incredible hulk to stay strong so
banner can basically control the hulk's
strength right remember that's kind of
the thing that's going on here it's
interesting and it's kind of meta
textual but in the midst of all this
kind of happening the incredible whole
persona meets with what looks like this
kind of dark demonic devil hulk version
the crazy thing is that he seems to have
seen him before it's one of those things
where he's like you right like who are
you and then when this version takes off
the whole kind of chases after him right
and he's like please come back so it's
an interesting concept because it looks
as though the incredible hulk wants this
kind of devil version of himself or this
being or whatever it is this happens to
be again we don't fully know what's
going on here the important thing that
to really discuss here is basically
maine marvel universe banner talking to
alternate banner and what we get is this
bit of an origin story in that this
alternate reality universe version of
bruce banner says that unlike the main
marvel universe where the gamma bomb had
gone off but banner had basically pushed
rick jones out of the way was exposed to
the radiation and then became the
incredible hulk leading to general
thunderbolt ross and all those guys
writing the whole thing off as a failure
and basically saying aftermath of this
is basically just too dangerous that in
this alternate reality it worked right
the gamma bomb went off without a hitch
banner was not caught in the blast he
never became the incredible hulk or
anything along those lines but in his
naivety he believed that this would only
lead to a kind of second atomic age
right that in the aftermath of humanity
discovering atomic energy that yeah i
mean it gave us the cold war and the
fear that the united states and the
soviet union were going to wipe
themselves off the map but it also gave
us microwaves and all kinds of
technology and so the thought of banner
is that sure this could potentially be
used for destructive capabilities but if
for no other reason than
self-preservation humanity would not
necessarily be quick on the trigger in
terms of just detonating all these gamma
bombs across the world in some major
conflict instead they would use gamma
technology as basically a source of
energy to kind of enter into a new age
of human evolution instead the worst
fears of banner come true that there
seemed to have been some kind of just
massive global calamity and what they
ended up doing with the powers that be
as he describes them taking their
weapons and then basically detonating
them across the world everywhere except
for the united states is hit and so what
he says that this whole thing had
basically turned the united states into
the greatest empire in the world
seemingly it was the u.s that struck
first for whatever reason which is not
really explained here what seems to have
happened is that the united states using
gamma bombs targeted the rest of the
world and then detonated all those gamma
bombs in populated areas across the
world leaving only itself as seemingly
the last functioning empire in the world
the last functioning country in the
world and so banner has basically been
trying to continually atone for his
sense and when the question's asked what
are you doing to to atone for your sins
how does all this work he basically says
that the ensuing radiation from these
gamma bomb attacks basically affected
everybody across the world those
individuals who weren't killed in the
explosions were transformed into hulks
but instead of them simply just being
like hulks as you expect them right just
like running around and like an
incredible hulk type person instead
they're all irradiated so some of them
look like look like crabs some of them
are just kind of like welded in place
and it's just like hulk heads or
whatever the case is and sometimes like
you do see a kind of version of the hulk
that basically escapes here's the irony
of all this this is almost exactly how
the events played out in greg pack's
planet hulk event as part of secret wars
right the big difference here is that in
that story everybody in the world were
changed into like tried and true
incredible hulks right incredible hulks
or she hooks and like that was basically
it they weren't really mutated or
anything like that it's just everybody
in the world became a hulk here it's
really a an interesting blend between
the events of greg pack's planet hulk
from secret wars which i think was part
of like war zones or something like that
and then uh the events of incredible
hulk the end by peter david right where
basically the world was destroyed in in
nuclear war all the heroes and all the
villains who basically died out and the
incredible hulk and banner were like the
last two people on earth until the bruce
banner persona had a heart attack and
died and then it was just the incredible
hulk and and i don't really know how a
persona has a heart attack and dies but
regardless it's a very interesting blend
between these two things the other part
of this is that because these hulks kind
of appear out in the world every once in
a while and because this alternate
reality version of banner referred to
them as abominations the question that
the main marvel universe banner is where
are they right when you find these hulks
and you capture them where do they go
what do you do with them and he's like i
found them in the same place that i
found you right out in the void that
basically what this alternate reality
version of banner has been doing is
every time he finds a hulk he basically
throws them out into the void of the
multiverse right just sort of throws
them out there into existence he doesn't
know what happens to them he doesn't
really know where they go and it's not
really his concern and he does this
because he's instructed to and when the
question's asked by banner who instructs
you to do this who tells you to just
throw these incredible hulks away right
to just throw them out right to maybe
study them for a little while and throw
them into the void who tells you this
who is the person that's in charge here
and the response to this alternate
reality version of banner is my father
is it's this father-in-law president
thunderbolt ross
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with donnie kate's run on the
incredible hulk and in the last video we
basically ended things seemingly with
this idea that bruce banner essentially
seemed to work for like general
thunderbolt ross or at the very least
was subservient to general thunderbolt
ross who of course had become president
of the united states now the other part
of this is this reality is given a
numerical designation which usually
happens faster than this but this is
referred to as earth 122 so maybe that's
something that will become important
later on down the line i'm not entirely
sure usually whenever marvel actually
assigns a numerical designation to an
alternate reality it usually means that
alternate reality will appear in the
future so again that's why i say you may
or may not want to keep it in the back
of your head the thing about this is
that as we know uh basically thunderbolt
ross ends up discovering or finding out
that there is a kind of enormous amount
of gamma energy that it basically spiked
from a specific mountain range and what
this does is it seems to indicate that
bruce banner is actually in hiding from
general thunderbolt ross that he's not
actually working for thunderbolt ross
per se and that what ends up happening
here is thunderbolt ross of course is
like send everything right like get all
the drop ships going and everything like
that and i want to be there when it all
happens now here's a thing to understand
this would never be allowed to happen
the president of the united states would
never be allowed to enter an active war
zone the secret service would keep that
from happening right just like the
president's not allowed to put himself
in harm's way like that i mean he
wouldn't even be allowed to get close he
would never be allowed to enter an
active war zone
but at the end of the day as grant
morrison once said this is comics and
none of it's real so why does it matter
so here's the thing about this the big
question that we kind of had to ask here
is what's going on with the rest of the
world now we don't necessarily get this
in depth we do get a couple questions
answered but really we basically end up
finding out that it's largely tony stark
who killed the world not tony stark
directly but the technology of tony
stark that what ended up happening is
that with everything following the way
that it did right the gamma revolution
as it was called all these people with
like gamma energy basically popping up
all over the place that what it did is
it made stark technologies essentially
obsolete now this is an important thing
because before tony stark became iron
man as most of you guys know he was a
weapons manufacturer and whether it's
because you've seen the movie or you've
read the comics it was basically the art
of war right the danger that comes with
war itself and like the loss of innocent
lives and the fact that tony stark was
forced to face that fact when he was
kidnapped well really during the vietnam
war in the comics versus uh during the
afghan conflict in uh in the movies that
he ended up turning over a new leaf and
basically using his technology in order
to one make the world better as well as
turning himself into an avenger the
difference here is that because this
whole gamma revolution happened before
tony stark became iron man or at least
maybe after he became iron man the stark
industries had no real value and so the
result of this is that tony stark filed
for bankruptcy right like literally his
company's value just plummeted because
he wasn't offering anything that was
better than the whole gamma revolution
right the idea of like gamma-powered
beings and so what this meant is that
eventually his company was absorbed now
we're not really told who it was that
absorbed his company whether it was
justin hammer or anything like that or
even just the federal government itself
the important thing here is that
ultimately tony stark ended up just
dying of his alcoholism right he ended
up being found dead outside of a bar
from alcohol toxicity and basically
chronic pancreatitis following that the
technology of tony stark was basically
used presumably by the government to
kind of bridge the gap between the gamma
radiation of the incredible hulk and the
technology of stark to create these
basically gamma-powered stark uh robots
right and then in turn they started
wiping out everything right like
literally the x-men popped up shortly
after that and they were all just
annihilated by the federal government
right just totally wiped out completely
now the thing about this is that this
looks like it takes place around the
time of giant size x-men so not only
were the x-men eradicated by the forces
of basically the government using stark
tech but they also nuked the entirety of
the xavier's school for gifted
youngsters now we're not really given
much outside of that it's really just
kind of banner reading about all this
stuff in this alternate reality but what
we can also largely surmise here is that
when he starts asking questions like is
there nobody left right what about blade
or moon knight or like captain america
or even like spider-man that like the
response of this alternate reality
banner is like i don't okay blade or
moon like i have no idea what you're
talking about so seemingly there is no
blade there is no moon knight which is
really kind of interesting because in
the main marvel universe eric brooks
became blade pretty early on and he's
been around for quite some time so
seemingly he may still be around and
just nobody knows about him or maybe he
just never really came into existence at
all uh captain america may still very
well be frozen in ice it's just one of
those things where we're not really
given a whole lot of answers maybe we
will get them at a later point in time
but at the moment we don't really know
what's happening the crazy thing about
this though is that in the middle of all
this you basically end up having like
the forces of thunderbolt ross so
basically the us government that descend
on this mountain range where you have
the main marvel universe banner and this
alternate reality banner and so what it
does is it leads to like alternate
banner basically telling like you know
the the main marvel universe panda right
don't go out there right like these this
is literally an army that's bred for the
purpose of destroying people like you
right like they they this this is not
like you running out there and dealing
with like bullets and things like that
they specialize in this and the way what
i'm getting is that once banner shows up
out there it's just like this colossal
army with this these giant mech suits
you know this reminds me of in a lot of
ways it reminds me of like days of
future past right it looks very very
similar to david's future past this is
one of the reasons why that story was so
landmark when it came out and why it has
such a strong legacy because so often
whenever you look at alternate reality
stories where essentially the
superheroes have basically been killed
off in some form or fashion usually by
the actions of the government itself
that it is some kind of days of future
past-esque scenario right the activation
of some version of the sentinel program
sometimes the signals become self-aware
other times the sentinels never deviate
from their programming they never become
self-aware and they just operate based
on the programming given to them by the
federal government but whatever it is
the funny thing about this is banner
tells his alternate reality counterpart
no no right i'm from a whole different
playing field like i am not these gamma
mutates that you see out there right
these gamma-ray radiated beings just
watch and learn my friend i'm on a whole
different level from these guys now once
he jumps out there and and literally
ross is just like fire right fire
everything they have then it initially
takes banner by surprise right like he
didn't really believe what alternate
banner was telling him until he was
being hit with all these lasers that are
literally piercing his skin right which
is a very difficult task to achieve but
in a world full of gamma irradiated
hulks it was only a matter of time
before these before technology was
developed that could overcome those
hulks and by extension overcome this one
but as you guys know and seemingly one
of the things that makes the main marvel
universe version of the incredible hulk
so unique is that the angrier he gets
the stronger he gets and so as a result
of this literally banner just like sets
the whole the whole engine system of the
incredible hulk to stage four now
remember those of you guys who are kind
of getting caught up here that basically
it's banner controlling the mind of the
incredible hulk and by setting the
engine to stage four what he's basically
doing is forcing the incredible hulk
personality to experience like all these
different horrors in these stages of
combat which in turn makes the
incredible hulk personality angrier and
it makes the incredible hulk's body
stronger and more durable which allows
banner to continue fighting in places
that he normally wouldn't be able to
fight the thing about this is that by
going to stage 4 it basically activates
a kind of hallucination of the marvel
zombies so literally while like the hulk
personality is just losing its mind
attacking all these marvel zombies it
amps him up more and more his healing
factor kicks in he recovers almost
instantaneously and then like the
strength boost comes and in doing so he
starts laying waste to the forces of
thunderbolt ross right like at that
point it's really thunderbolt ross
realizing he never had a chance in the
first place right like it's just
absolute madness here and even this
alternate reality version of banner is
like my god like what the hell have i
unleashed right they have never seen
anything like this in this alternate
universe they've never seen like a tried
and true incredible hulk and that's one
of the things that donnie kate's really
seems to be hitting at is that yes you
have different iterations of the
incredible hulk from around the
multiverse but there only ever really
seems to be one version of the
incredible hulk that's as unique as this
now the reality is we know that's not
necessarily the case right i mean the
what if story based on like world war
hulk where basically hulk ends up
killing all the superheroes and becomes
a hero of galactus like that was
basically the same hulk that we were
used to who seemingly had all the same
powers right so it's not that uncommon
to see but it seems to be a fairly rare
thing and so what you end up getting is
actually general thunderbolt ross who
contacts this alternate banner and is
just like do something right like call
this guy off if you don't call this guy
off then i'm bringing out your star
pupil right this stupid kid that you
love so much and we're gonna send them
down there and so that's the crazy thing
is because where where ross is like you
got 10 seconds right banner like
literally tries to talk him down he's
like no no like please don't do it
please don't do it he was like call your
monster off or the boy falls right the
boy gets knocked down into this whole
great big huge thing and so it's one of
those things where like this alternate
reality banner absolutely cares for this
kid right but at the end of the day he
ends up coming to thunderbolt ross and
then tells bruce banner you have to stop
this madness right you have to stop
fighting against the forces of ross and
like the whole time bruce banner's like
what are you talking about why do i have
to stop fighting and he never really
gets an answer he doesn't shut off the
engine right he doesn't doesn't calm the
incredible hulk down that the incredible
persona keeps going crazy just like it
always did and so as a result of that
the countdown ends and ross is just like
dunzo and kicks the kid out of this
whole thing and so you have bruce banner
talking to his alternate reality banner
counterpart and it's like tell me what's
going on like what's happening here and
this alternate reality banner is like
okay so here's the thing right like this
kid was basically my star pupil right
like he was he was just he was a
research student of mine right he was
like a son to me his name was peter and
he was bitten by a spider that we had
basically irradiated now when that
happens right in that moment the forces
of general thunderbolt ross retreat they
clear the battlefield and when bruce
banner asks the question okay this is
probably stupid but this irradiated
spider that bit this kid peter what kind
of radiation are we talking about here
and what it looks like is it was a gamma
irradiated spider because what manifests
here is one of the most badass
depictions of spider-man ever right like
literally this kid lands here and he
ends up transforming into what's
basically a hulk spider-man it is
awesome oh my god you look so good this
is why i love donnie kate's man the guy
just pulls these crazy ass rabbits out
of his ass right it's just it's nuts the
kind of stuff that he does this guy's
imagination is just bonkers
okay so getting back into donnie kate's
hulk run right picking up where we left
off and we'll kind of explain what's
going on to a degree as we go through
this as we usually do just because of
the fact that we're doing these like a
month apart we basically pick up in this
alternate universe with this alternate
reality version of bruce banner and we
pick up with this alternate reality
version of general thunderbolt ross now
there is this really really amazing
monologue that the that banner does like
the the main marvel universe banner the
incredible hulk does as all this is
happening because remember he's
basically uh fighting this alternate
reality version of spider-man who was
also exposed to gamma radiation so like
spider hulk essentially and what he says
here is he says he wanted to be so much
more than this right he wanted to push
the boundaries explore the unknowable
that he wanted to discover and invent to
create instead on this world every world
that has ever known the name bruce
banner the story is always the same like
this alternate me the banner of this
world once said i am become death again
and again and again the destroyer of
worlds now i love that quote i don't
know where how many of you guys know
where that's from but it's it actually
comes from a from a hindu scripture but
it was really it really became a staple
of pop culture because of robert
oppenheimer after the detonation of the
atomic bomb when it was experimented
witnessing the first detonation um in
1945 after the manhattan project he said
i remember the line from the hindu
scripture the bhagavad-gita vishnu is
trying to persuade the prince that he
should do his duty and to impress him
takes on his multi-armed form and says
now i am become death the destroyer of
worlds i absolutely love that quote i've
always loved that quote right it's one
of my absolute favorite quotes when it
comes to the the history just just in
general right it's just it's an amazing
quote but nonetheless right this
alternate reality version of bruce is
basically being pummeled by thunderbolt
ross now remember they kind of worked
together to a degree right that raw
seemingly in this universe and virtually
every other has never really liked bruce
banner but the the i guess maybe
alliance between the two despite it
being tenuous was predicated on the idea
that in the attempt of this alternate
reality version of banner to solve the
bio waste problem and accidentally
creating all these different versions of
hulks essentially some of whom are
grotesquely mutated others are
relatively normal in terms of their
appearance that
in order to correct this mistake they
would basically send them through a
wormhole and who knows where they would
go now one of the things that donnie
kate's tells us is that ultimately we'll
find out where they go to
[Laughter]
we'll find out where it is that they all
end up at but regardless it's just this
really really cool moment because what
ross wants here in basically pummeling
this alternate reality version of banner
is he wants to know what this hulk is
where it came from and how to kill it
and that's the crazy thing is because
this version of hulk this alternate
reality hulk represents this huge threat
to this alternate version of thunderbolt
ross because it could destabilize
everything he's built now remember in
terms of how the incredible hulk
operates right now it's the incredible
hulk strength that is basically
motivated by the incredible hulk itself
that what you have here is you have
banner who controls the mind of the
incredible hulk and that he basically
forces the incredible hulk psyche to
face off against all these different
threats and as you guys know the longer
a fight goes on for and the more
difficult it becomes for the incredible
hulk to defeat a foe the angrier the
incredible hulk becomes and the angrier
the hulk becomes the stronger he becomes
so quite literally bruce banner has
turned the incredible whole persona into
a source of power that he can manipulate
right he can literally ramp it up by
stages ramp it down by stages have them
face off against all kinds of credible
threats and so the result of this is
right now they're at stage four
basically the incredible hulk persona is
fighting marvel zombies in his own mind
and because the incredible hulk cannot
differentiate right it's basically a
child it doesn't know that what it's
seeing is not real it thinks it is and
so it's just pummeling everything it
sees and as the fight continues to go on
the incredible hulk persona gets angrier
and angrier and gets stronger and
stronger and so because of this again
betty ross has intermittently kind of
appeared in the mind of banner and just
kind of talked to him occasionally and
one of the things that she says is she
asked like what are you doing right like
you know you're not gonna kill that poor
thing and the responsive banner is i
mean like what are you talking about and
the answer that betty offers is like
he's just a child right he can't help
what he is and that's when banner gets a
little irritated and just kind of like
you know what is this right since when
do you care so much about protecting
these supposed children why is this so
important to you and that's when when
betty's like bruce i don't exist right
i'm not a i'm a manifestation of your
own mind but she says i know what
happens when you lock a child away and
abuse it when you take its freedoms away
it's agency it bottles all of that up
right all of that fury all of that rage
when you do that bruce the child turns
into what made it you know this better
than anyone you were turned into what
you are by your father right like you
hurt people you did bad things to people
right like the incredible hulk persona
is a manifestation of the abuse you
experience at the hands of your father
right rage given a physical form and she
says now you have to ask yourself if you
lock the hulk away and you keep hurting
it keep making it angrier making it
bottle up all of that rage when that
child explodes what will he turn into
and the responsive manner is i don't
know but let's find out and that's when
he ramps it up to stage five in order to
defeat this you know mutated version of
spider-man and at this point now it's
fighting gods it's fighting cerner and
like thor and beta ray bill and like
loki and all these people which again
makes the hulk angrier and angrier now
the hulk is able to overcome this uh
this this mutated spider you know spider
hulk he's able to overcome him but at
that point or at least kind of get the
fight to the point where spider spider
hulk is on the ropes but what you do
here is you basically switch over to
this alternate reality version of banner
and it says like i tried to tell you
everything like i've told you everything
i know right like there's no conceivable
way that i know of to kill this version
of the incredible hulk and that's when
you end up having uh having thunderbolt
ross who lays his chips on the on the
table right he tells he tells the guys
to leave and he basically reveals his
hand and what he says here is that in
reality uh at the end of the day when it
came to like all these different
versions of the hulk that this alternate
reality version of banner had
accidentally created that general
thunderbolt ross wasn't just getting rid
of them indiscriminately that what he
was doing was actually weaponizing them
that the ones who were weaker the ones
who couldn't serve a useful purpose they
were all discarded they were sent to the
portal to end up wherever it was that
they ended up at but the reality is the
ones who were stronger the ones who
could be used for warfare right that
they were kept and in fact reed richards
in this alternate universe had actually
made it possible for thunderbolt ross to
essentially control these versions of
the hulk and then in turn they've used
them to fight wars right then one of the
things that thunderbolt ross has said is
that he had to use the ordinance that's
the equivalent to the gdp of multiple
nations that have been conscripted or
taken over by the us so what this means
and what this seems to indicate is that
the geopolitical landscape is not the
way that it is in the main marvel
universe it's not the united states of
america canada mexico russia any of the
number of countries that are in europe
right china that instead things seem to
have changed drastically and we don't
necessarily know what what continents or
what nations the united states has taken
over but the united states has taken
over a lot of them right they they seem
to control a huge part of the world and
the incredible hulks that were basically
being taken by uh by thunderbolt ross
that had accidentally been created by
banner they were instrumental in making
that happen and so while it's not
necessarily the fault of banner
thunderbolt ross plays it off by saying
in a way it is like you sure like all
these incredible hulks they were an
accident created by you it wasn't your
intention you were just trying to solve
the biowaste problem but you literally
gave us weapons and while i never told
you before i used them to win wars right
i just kind of kept it hidden from you
and so that's the crazy thing is because
what happens is that in the middle of
all this you have the fight going on
between hulk and and you know spider
hulk in the actual real world right
that's where that fight is taking place
but the reality is all these bombs are
dropped by thunderbolt ross right and
when that happens it's not enough to
kill spider hulk or anything but it's
certainly enough to basically destroy
the visor of uh of banner and when that
happens like banner is like literally
the whole thing goes nuts right like
banner's just kind of blown out of a
seat and all that kind of stuff and
while it is a little weird because
banner is supposed like this is the
physical body of the hulk so it's
basically the the the psyche of banner
the psyche of the incredible hulk
basically you know kind of operating
inside this body uh that banner is
actually overtaken by the psyche of
betty ross that the the kind of physical
representation we get here at least as
far as we can tell is basically banner
just kind of being thrown out there it's
not really banner being thrown into the
physical real world instead what it is
is it's actually banner just being
thrown out of control right that
basically betty ross is taking over
that's kind of how that works right so
those of you guys who are watching like
moon night right now for example you
know how like the the minds switch
between like steve grant and mark
spector this is the equivalent of when
like mark spector takes over and steve
grant ends up going back there but
instead of steve grant like really
relinquishing control uh mark spector
just takes control
that's basically how this is working
right now to give you guys a better
understanding of what's going on because
i know like on the surface just looking
at it it's like wait a minute okay so
like does banner physically exist no
it's basically just the betty ross
persona taking over the body of the
incredible hulk and forcing the bruce
banner persona into the background right
and so because of this what you also end
up learning here is that this isn't
actually betty ross it looks like it's
betty ross but it's not actually betty
ross right one of the things she says is
that where banner's begging right like
you have to help me here the the
response she gives is like look at you
right helpless trapped at the mercy of
forces and violence out of your control
remind you of anybody and and ultimately
she says you never really listen do you
right i told you bruce betty isn't real
betty's not here and what she does is
she ramps the engine up and basically
takes it to stage six and so now you
have the incredible hulk persona facing
off against demons mephisto dormammu
right all these different guys now
here's kind of a funny caveat to this
right here's something that you may not
have noticed one of the things that
donnie cates is doing is giving us a
hierarchy of power in marvel comics it's
very easy to miss it's very easy to not
notice but he's giving us a hierarchy of
power that in essence you have stage one
which is kind of a relatively small
threat but as the stages go up the
beings become more powerful it wouldn't
really make any sense to ramp the
incredible hulk up to stage six and then
like here comes the red skull it
wouldn't really make any sense to do
that
and so donnie kate's is in effect giving
us a hierarchy of power in the marvel
universe i can guarantee you people are
going to reference this right you go and
you look at like battle forms and
different things like that or you ask
people you know in different forms like
who you know who's more powerful you
know like uh odin or or like dormammu
right people are going to be like well i
mean according to donnie cases and you
know hulk run it looks like it's
dormammu because dormammu was a stage
six villain or stage six power and odin
was stage five you know and that kind of
a thing right but it's a cool little
aside here it's it's a smart little
thing and so in the end one of the
things that happens is that general
thunderbolt ross reveals to bruce banner
this alternate version of bruce that
these bombs that he dropped are not
bombs in the traditional sense instead
what they are here are basically a means
of mutation that what's happening is
that inside each one of these canisters
are basically people that had become
that had been mutated even though
unintentionally by banner but the ones
that thunderbolt ross had kept and that
these as thunderbolt rossa first refers
to them are basically just like
abominations right kind of like this
alternate reality version of abomination
here and so it's nuts because these
things are massive in size right they're
absolutely huge in size and so of course
this basically leads to betty completely
taking over the body of the incredible
hulk completely pushing banner's persona
out of the way but in doing so she says
but i'm proud of you son and that's
where it seems to hit this idea that
this is potentially brian banner now
this is where things get a little murky
because in al ewing's ron one of the
things to remember in the immortal hulk
is that it wasn't necessarily brian
banner it kind of was but it was
basically brian banner's spirit or
essence that had been overtaken by the
one below all and used to torment the
incredible hulk that's what that was it
wasn't actually brian banner himself and
so what this does is it builds on what
we've seen both in al ewing's runs a lot
of runs that came before it bill mantlo
peter david where basically the brian
banner persona is kind of the uh the
controlling aspect now that's me
guessing here right just going on what's
sort of happening in terms of words that
brian banner is the source of bruce
banner's torment and seemingly the most
powerful entity in his mind the one
thing that banner just can't seem to
overcome but i could be entirely wrong
here this could very well be the the
mental persona of the titan hulk right
like we don't know we won't know until
we get to the next issue but ultimately
that this persona ends up ramping
everything up right like right past
stage seven and and right past stage
eight all the way to stage nine which is
basically just who really even knows
what this stage looks like presumably
it's the titan hulk but whatever it is
it literally leads to the incredible
hulk just absolutely
losing it and annihilating all these
different abomination forces that are
out there and that's where it ends so
presumably this is where titan hulk
comes into play and if it does
i can't wait to see how this plays out
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with donny kate smashernaut
with the finale and we finally get the
titan hulk the most powerful version of
the hulk that we've ever seen now for
those of you guys who want to get caught
up make sure you check the link in the
description or you can click on the card
here in the video which will take you to
the hulk playlist that will get you
caught up on all this stuff but the long
and short of it is that the incredible
hulk is basically here in an alternate
reality and is facing off against these
altered versions of the hulk basically
um these accidentally created versions
but the thing about this is that
remember bruce banner was the one
controlling the body of the hulk and
that the incredible hulk persona is in
the engine room basically serving as a
source of power because of its anger and
that somehow an alternate personality
which seems to be brian banner although
donnie kate's hasn't necessarily
confirmed it has now seized control so
it's like if the incredible hulk body
was being controlled by an evil
personality is basically what it is now
the way in which uh bruce banner
basically amped up the incredible hulk
or brought him down in terms of like how
much power he would need to face off
against a particular threat was
basically forcing the incredible hulk
personality to fight different levels of
villains that are out there so at the
baseline level is like the incredible
hulk just walking along right and maybe
fighting fighting some guy or you know
fighting the avengers or something like
that in the real world and so in the
engine room it would be these baseline
villains really like nobody of any real
significance what we're seeing here is
what happens when that's amped up all
the way to 10. when basically it's the
most amount of power that could be taken
out of the incredible hulk right like
literally pushing him to his to his
highest level now donnie cates doesn't
necessarily confirm this but what he
says here or at least what this
indicates is if this is the most amount
of strength the incredible hulk can
possibly offer basically pushing him to
the limit then it's way beyond anything
we've ever seen and the highest amount
of power that we'd seen from the
incredible hulk up to this point was
heart of the monster when he was so
strong he was actually breaking the dark
dimension the the dimension of dormammu
which at the time was ruled by his
sister umar who literally showed up in
the main marvel universe asking doctor
strange for help because the incredible
hulk just couldn't be stopped i mean it
was crazy how powerful he was still one
of the best stories ever again that's in
the playlist as well if you guys want to
get caught up on that but the thing
about this is that with this personality
running the show it's really just kind
of offering this amazing meta commentary
coming in the form of betty ross albeit
seemingly actually being somebody else
what we're told here is that it says
everyone always says the same thing that
the hulk is bruce's identity right his
alter ego the embodiment of a scared
little boy overwhelmed with impotent
rage because of the abuse he endured
when he was a little kid blah blah blah
blah yadda yadda right she just kind of
shuffles it off and that's true that's
one of the best things about this is
this donny kade's kind of offering this
meta commentary now for those of you
guys who don't know what this means uh
as we're going through this i'll kind of
give you guys a little bit of a little
bit of a background here although you do
get an amazing moment where you
basically have like when it's amped up
to level 10 which according to bruce
banner is basically theoretical he
doesn't even really know what would
happen if that were the case that
basically it's the hulk versus the
entire marvel universe which in which
includes the living tribunal thanos and
a version of galactus who is the hulk
now there's a reason behind that and
i'll explain that here in a second
because unless you're familiar with
galactus you wouldn't know why galactus
looks like the incredible hulk and even
this personality doesn't know which is
uh which is a really really cool concept
so the thing about this is that when it
comes to
the incredible hulk mythos most people
out here whenever they go and they buy
an incredible whole comic book and they
read an incredible whole comic book what
they want to see is the incredible hulk
just smashing that's what they want to
see
[Laughter]
they want to see the incredible hulk
fighting really powerful people and
beating them up and just tearing things
up because that's what the hulk is known
for now people who want a more like
character-centric run that was the old
bill mantlow and peter david stuff greg
pack focused on that to a degree but it
was more expanding the incredible hulk
mythos and then focusing on like the
character of the hulk insofar as it
related to like hirokala and scar the
sons he didn't know he had which were
really really cool and there were a few
other things that went in there but in
terms of like a character deconstruction
of the hulk what's being referenced here
in terms of the fact that like the
incredible whole personality is the
physical manifestation of just all the
rage that bruce banner experienced at
the hands of his father's abuse that's
all bill mantlow and peter david it was
initially started by bill mantlo back in
the day but he took off before he could
finish and then peter david continued it
on and that's why one a lot of people
say the two go hand in hand that when it
comes to that era of the incredible hulk
is bill mantlow and peter david together
and two a lot of people say that peter
david's run of the incredible hulk is
one of the most important runs it's not
the most interesting run especially when
you compare it to something like greg
pack which had a lot more action and a
lot more character development but in
terms of everything greg pack did that
was built on the shoulders of peter
david so peter david's run it's probably
one of the most significant runs it for
no other reason than the fact that it
just sort of changed the hulk from like
the old stanley jack kirby days where
he's just like you know a monster
running around with the mind of a child
and like beating things up and like
fighting general thunderbolt ross and
his army and so on and so forth
especially if you look at the roy thomas
era as well and it changed him into like
there's actually more to the incredible
hulk than we initially thought now as
far as this whole scenario goes when it
comes to like why uh galactus looks like
the incredible hulk i mean technically
it is the incredible hulk versus
galactus the living tribunal and the
phoenix force it is here in the engine
room but the reason why is something
that was established in a story called
the trial of reed richards and we talked
about this before but basically that set
up the idea that galactus does not
actually have a physical form anymore he
did back when he was gallon before his
universe before the multiverse was
destroyed and then he reemerged after
merging with that universe's version of
eternity essentially when he was reborn
into the new universe as galactus uh he
had a human form back when he was
initially just what you would call a
human or a sentient being but when he
was reborn as galactus he's pure energy
and so if you saw him as he really is it
would just be a swirling mass of energy
inside of a giant purple suit and
there's one point where odin like
headbutts galactus and shatters his
helmet uh which i'm pretty sure we did a
video on that and that in turn you
actually see galactus in what looks like
his human form but the reality here is
it's how an asgardian would see him
because in the trial of reed richards
what they set up and what they stated is
that galactus is a mirror for whatever
race or whatever being sees him so if
you are a scroll and you see galactus he
will look like a scroll if you are a
tree he'll look like a kree if you're a
human he'll look human and so if you're
an asgardian he'll probably look like an
asgardian which is why in this instance
the incredible hulk sees galactus and he
sees an incredible hulk so so the thing
about this and what's really cool is the
hulk literally amps up and starts
attacking everything right starts
attacking all of them now the funny
thing about this is during this whole
this whole situation the entire
monologue offered by this betty brandt
we can call her betty brant right this
betty brand-esque person which is most
likely brian banner that literally it
says over the years there have been so
many hulks gray ones red ones blue ones
wolverine ones which is actually called
weapon h and he was not that interesting
uh she says it seems to me that well
everyone gets to have a hulk these days
bruce has a hulk rick jones had a hulk
general thunderbolt ross had a hulk
jennifer walters even had a hulk and she
said hell even god has a hulk which is
cool to see donnie cates referencing the
al ewing run where we basically learned
that the the one below all is what
happens when god hulks out and so she's
like it's really unfair isn't it like
why can't the hulk have a hulk now this
and this gives us two things one is a
retcon that everyone's glide happened
and two is a new version of the hulk and
so what we end up getting like as this
fight goes on technically the betty ross
persona is in the mind of the incredible
hulk in the real world the incredible
hulk is fighting in this alternate
reality against like all these different
just grotesque and mutilated versions of
the hulk remember in this alternate
universe there was an effort to
basically utilize gamma energy as a
source of renewable energy things went
wrong and instead of becoming a
renewable energy source it ended up
mutating a whole host of the world's
population into these different versions
of the hulk and that's what the
incredible hulk's fighting now in the
real world so that's why i say it's
something to kind of keep in mind donnie
kate's does it a little finicky right he
does a little a little weird but
essentially anytime you see somebody
that looks like they're in a cockpit
they're in the mind of the incredible
hulk when you see the version of the
incredible hulk that looks like a robot
kind of that's basically him in the real
world so just something to keep in mind
here the thing about this is that as
this fight goes on because the hulk is
being so readily overpowered and quite
literally being slapped around what it
ends up doing is the incredible hulk
himself hulks out now this is something
marvel had done before and it was asked
so in the story of axis basically the
incredible hulk hulked out into
basically claw which was the incredible
hulk spell backwards it was a terrible
idea uh ridiculously dumb and so what we
got instead of that was this like donnie
cage just being like this is what
happens when the hulk hulks out uh he
ends up becoming the titan hulk which is
nuts because he literally looks part
machine like it's just ridiculously op
which is absolutely amazing i love this
i mean dude the guy's just spewing
energy everywhere but this is why i say
this is what it looks like this is
seemingly the most powerful version of
the incredible hulk that we've ever seen
now there there are huge differences
between this version of the hulk and
like heart of the monster in looking at
these two you kind of have to come from
a feats perspective and in terms of like
what each one is capable of we saw what
the heart of the monster hulk was able
to do i mean again shattering and like
breaking apart the dimension of one of
the most powerful magic wielders in
existence which depending on who's
writing the story dwarfs the power of
doctor strange that is
crazy like literally them having to take
off in their dimension and ask doctor
strange for help to deal with that
version of the incredible hull so we're
not really seeing those same levels of
feats now i would be curious to see what
happens if the titan hulk ends up in the
dark dimension again and how that
unfolds it would be pretty wild and it
would be pretty cool but this is what
happens with the incredible hulks just
strength rage anger all that kind of
stuff and really fear take hold and is
pushed to the absolute limit we just get
this massively grotesque huge thing
right and literally what what they're
saying is they're like i've never seen
anything like this before it's like 30
feet tall like this thing is enormous
right i mean he's just huge like it's
just it's it's amazing
[Laughter]
i absolutely love this so again here in
the real world in this alternate reality
you have general thunderbolt ross and
you have this alternate reality version
of bruce banner and this alternate
version of bruce was in a lot of ways
kind of subservient to general
thunderbolt ross but only in so far as
this alternate reality version of bruce
was basically a coward wrecked by guilt
and fear and so on and so forth and so
the reality here is thunderbolt ross
basically ends up getting on a getting
on the radio and calling in like a gamma
bomb detonation now the way this works
seemingly what would happen here is
somehow gamma radiation has been altered
by general thunderbolt ross to where
it's more akin to like a nuclear
explosion right enough that it would
just eradicate everything here and in
truth usually when it comes to like a
nuclear bomb or something like that it's
a combination of heat and force and
radiation right i mean if you're at
ground zero when a nuclear warhead goes
off or a nuclear bomb detonates which
technically it doesn't detonate on the
ground it detonates a little into the a
little above ground ah just to maximize
the area of destruction i mean you would
be incinerated by the heat immediately
and assuming you weren't incinerated by
the heat if you're close enough to the
blast i mean you'd probably be knocked
into a building and just just killed
that way right your skull would be
crushed by the impact but assuming that
doesn't happen the radiation sickness
would probably kill you as well right i
mean there's a lot of ways to die as a
result of a nuclear bomb going off but
like that really seems to be what it is
here right it would just be like
couldn't like literally just heat and
pressure is basically what general
thunderbolt ross is banking on whether
or not it would work we don't know i
mean there are literally been instances
where like the incredible hulk who's
just kind of angry has been able to
withstand the power of a nuclear bomb
even maestro right like literally
maestro hulk absorbed the radiation that
came from nuclear bombs so we've seen
different variations of the hulk over
the years who could easily withstand a
nuclear explosion how a gamma a
weaponized gamma explosion would impact
the hulk i don't entirely know i mean
literally the hulk is living gamma
radiation my assumption would be that he
would just absorb it but the reality
here and the point that this alternate
version of bruce banner brings up is
that thunderbolt ross can't do that like
it's a terrible thing to do because if
he did thousands of people would die
because while we don't see them because
they're not the main focus here there's
basically a populated area right it's
not overly populated and they kind of
seem to be off out there and a little
bit of a distance but the the explosion
radius would be high enough it would be
wide enough that it would kill so many
innocent people and that in turn
thunderbolt ross just kind of like
overpowering or really just sort of
directing bruce banner is like no like i
don't care in the end like we'll both
end up killing thousands of people and
he says because remember you're the
reason why these different versions of
the hulk exist in the first place and
you're the one that brought this
alternate hulk here so really this is
all your fault now the reality here is
his thunderbolt ross to a degree trying
to assuage his guilty conscience if he
even has one and just trying to bring
bruce banner down with him but where
this version of bruce is kind of a
depiction of what would happen if bruce
banner just never grew any balls he
never became the incredible hulk and was
never like an enemy of thunderbolt ross
insofar as he was able to overpower him
likely humiliate him a few times that
the only thing he really can do is
muster up what courage he has and he in
turn attacks thunderbolt ross and is
like no i'm not going to let you kill
thousands of people now while you know
within the context of this particular
story it doesn't seem significant or at
least this particular video over the
course of the videos that we've covered
it's a huge moment because this
alternate reality version of bruce was
constantly racked by guilt and
constantly felt like he was making
terrible mistakes and even then he
didn't realize that where he was
basically sending all these different
versions of the hulk that they caught
across their world into the ether right
into some into some portal somewhere
with no clue where they went to that
what was really going on is that he was
sending the ones out there that general
thunderbolt ross didn't want that what
thunderbolt ross was doing was going
around and grabbing those different
versions of the hulk that he could use
that were that he thought were
weaponized so in reality he was at least
by his own imagination and kind of using
his own mind feeding into his own guilt
he was the reason why all these
different abominaze versions of the hulk
were continuing to live these terrible
existences under the servitude of
general thunderbolt ross because he
didn't know but had he not done what he
done in creating the gamma detonation
trying to create some kind of renewable
energy they never would have been left
to that fate in the first place so the
screwed up world in which bruce banner
lives here he largely takes as being his
fault him attacking thunderbolt ross
overpowering him pointing that gun at
him and saying no like you're not going
to kill anybody anymore this is
seemingly him overcoming that guilt and
accepting that not everything bad that's
going on now is his fault right that
like there are some things out there
that are just the results of the fact
that people are dicks right like gender
general thunderball ross is just a
terrible person who is doing terrible
things and despite what thunderbolt ross
said it was not the fault of bruce
banner now the other part of this is
that in the mindscape of the incredible
hulk bruce banner kind of claws his way
back into to the incredible hulk's mind
more or less where he was just kind of
out there basically it was a it was an
in-comic representation of the fact that
like the bruce banner persona was forced
to take a back seat so ultimately of
course with him coming back in we do get
this version of betty ross's personality
which seemingly kind of alters and kind
of changes and takes on this different
form again we don't know exactly what
this is but i would go as far as to say
if the titan hulk is what happens when
the hulk hooks out that this is the
mental representation of what the titan
hulk looks like we don't know that for
sure we're not 100 certain but in the
end there's this kind of discussion
where literally the personality is like
you have no power here banner right like
you are weak you are pathetic you cannot
take control you cannot wrestle control
of the body away from me and the
response of a banner is i know but he
has the power to do it and in doing so
flips the switch like literally hits the
emergency switch and allows the
incredible hulk persona to come in now
here's the thing it's amazing the way
this is drawn right like literally the
door is just half open and like the
incredible hulk persona is just there
and it's like the head of galactus is
behind him and he looks pissed and he
comes smashing in here so what you're
seeing here right now is basically a
battle of personalities right it's the
incredible hulk personality versus the
bruce banner personality versus whatever
this new alternate personality is which
is seemingly the personality of the
titan hulk i would go as far as to say
that was the case but the way this is
drawn can get really really
hairy and a little bit confusing and so
in essence what happens here is that in
the mind of the incredible hulk right
where you basically have the bruce
banner personality the titan hulk
personality and the incredible hulk
personality the incredible hulk
personality is able to beat back the
titan hulk personality in the real world
the titan hulk itself is literally just
unbridled energy that it just can't
control and so because it has all this
energy and because it doesn't know how
to control all this energy like this is
seemingly just a mindless thing it
literally just roars we never really
hear it speak or anything like that that
in the end all this energy just kind of
explodes in a massive explosion right it
just goes off right it literally just
blows up and so what you have here at
least momentarily is essentially a
reunification of personalities the titan
hulk personality has been beat back to
wherever it came from we don't really
know where it came from but presumably
it just resides down there in the
mindscape somewhere and that as a result
of the destruction of the quote unquote
real world titan hulk uh now it's
basically just the incredible hulk back
in its normal form and so at this point
banner basically runs back into the
cockpit right the mind of the incredible
hulk and in doing so receives his
control and as that goes on of course
this gamma bomb is falling and it is
gonna it's gonna cost so much life and
so what ends up happening is there's a
conversation between alternate reality
banner and the incredible hulk band
right banner one banner two banner three
but you end up having like this
this conversation between these where
alternate reality banner is like look
this gamma bombs falling you have to do
something right like i have an idea and
so you know prime banner we can call him
that banner from the main marvel
universe it's like then what do you want
me to do and alternate banners like i'm
opening a portal and basically that bomb
is gonna come through that portal and
it's gonna land here right it's gonna
end up here where i am but in the end
it's the rightful thing to do i've
caused nothing but just death and
destruction and just horrible things uh
i wouldn't go i mean he doesn't go as
far as to say like it's the fate that
awaits me but he says like i really hope
that you don't end up like me i really
hope that you don't end up in this place
where you're basically like this kind of
horrible terrible villain what you have
here in the form of the incredible hulk
is quite literally a gift use it right
like use it as a gift treat it with
respect but use it to do good things now
this is actually a really really cool
concept because what this does is it
gives us perspective that the only real
perspective we have when it comes to the
incredible hulk is what we've seen over
the course of marvel comics and
potentially some alternate realities and
unless you're looking at like warren
ellis's marvel the m you don't really
see a whole lot of like totally screwed
up twisted up versions of the incredible
hulk but that's all this alternate
reality banner knows are just twisted
screwed up versions of the hulk and so
as a result of this once that bomb goes
through and of course it ends up
detonating that the portal is reopened
and banner or at least the incredible
hulk anyway travels through it to
wherever his destination ends up taking
him next he has no clue where it is that
he's going to end up going all he knows
is that literally at the moment the
hammer of all father thor which was
recently reassembled by angela and the
angels of heaven is making its way
towards the hulk so in essence what
we're apparently going to see here which
makes perfect sense because literally
it's the 60th anniversary of the
incredible hulk and thor fighting for
the first time that what we're gonna end
up getting is all father thor against
probably the titan hulk which i am
ridiculously excited to see but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end in order to make all this
easier to understand we're just gonna
make it into a full story it should make
it a whole lot easier to follow but i
will catch you all later
peace